oui
ce n'est pas juste de la Russie de faire ça
et ce n'est pas juste d'autres pays
de rester et de regarder
c'est toute cette situation n'est pas bonne
je ne sais pas comme si j'étais excité de rencontrer
ma famille ainsi que trois ans je n'ai pas
vu mon  famille en ukraine
donc je suis ravi de voir ma famille j'ai
hâte que ce soit une
sorte de sortie aussi parce que
c'est beaucoup plus difficile parce que mon ami
m'a dit d'ici au canada qu'il est
ukrainien aussi et il dit comme tu le sais
comme
je suis jaloux
[Musique  ]
ouais et
ouais, c'est tout ce que nous
aimons donner aux gens et nous
collectons ce dont nous avons le plus
besoin en ce moment, alors
vous